(soft music)
- [Host] This map shows the maximum range
of China's land-based conventional
strike missiles in 2015.
Less than a decade later,
that range has doubled,
putting all American bases
in the Asia Pacific, including
Guam within the range
of precision missiles fired
from the Chinese mainland.
A secretive Chinese
military unit is responsible
for that expansion, and now
controls one of the largest
and most diverse land-based
missile forces in the world.
Details of the force are some
of China's most tightly guarded secrets,
but Western intelligence agencies
and researchers have revealed
evidence of its dramatic rise.
- China has rapidly increased
its missile arsenal.
This is a menacing challenge
to the United States.
(upbeat music)
- [Host] In August, 2023,
Chinese leader Xi Jinping
suddenly ousted and replaced the head
of an opaque military unit
called the rocket force.
China's leaders have tasked this force
with its highest military objective.
(group cheering)
Preparing for a possible
invasion of Taiwan
(bombs exploding)
and deterring the United
States from intervening.
(man speaking foreign language)
- [Host] In recent years,
the force has test launched
hundreds of ballistic missiles
at a rate that has exceeded
the rest of the world combined.
Alexander Neal is a former defense
analyst for the British government.
- The PLA rocket force has
six bases spread across China
in an arc in the south,
which are responsible for
a potential Taiwan conflict.
Then up in the Northeast,
which is responsible
for Korean Peninsula
and targeting Japan,
there's a dedicated base in central China.
And finally, a base which
is responsible for the
northwest of China.
- [Host] On top of these six main bases,
which are numbered from 61 to 66,
the rocket force also has
several supporting bases,
one of which is regarded
as the most important.
- Base 67 is the most secretive
of the PLA rocket force basis.
The guardian of China's
strategic nuclear deterrent.
(soft music)
- Little is known about
the base in Baoji City
in central China, but bunkers dug into
the Qinling Mountain
Range on the outskirts
of the city houses most of China's
nuclear warheads stockpile.
- From Base 67, the warheads
subsequently distributed
by rail all across China,
northwest, northeast,
and into the south, across
the brigades responsible
for launch and deployments
of the nuclear deterrent.
(upbeat music)
- [Host] Bases in China's north are tasked
with maintaining nuclear capable
intercontinental ballistic
missiles focused on
targets on the US mainland.
- A number of scientists
looking at civilian imagery
spotted three new missile
silo fields under development.
(soft music)
The silo fields are based
in very deserted areas
outside of Hami, Yumen
City and Ordos City.
- [Host] Silos are built as
circular tubes into the ground
and contain propellants
to launch missiles.
- You can see here the Ordos silo field,
which is typically made up
of about 100 silos here.
An important aspect
of silo fields is something
called a shell game.
You might have 100 silos, but
you may fill only 50% of them,
and the adversary has to calculate which
of those silos are armed in
order to make a calculation
for a counterstrike.
And a shell game is designed
to keep the adversary guessing
and also to reserve your own
number of warheads as well.
- [Host] The construction in Ordos, Hami
and Yumen is thought to be
the most extensive buildup
of missile silos since the Cold War.
If China mounts nuclear warheads
on missiles in these silos,
it will present a huge strategic shift
for US military planners.
- You can see here that the arc
of the three silo fields is
designed to launch missiles
over the North Pole
and to the continental United States.
- [Host] All this could give
Beijing the military capability
to deter Washington from
engaging China militarily
in the event of an invasion of Taiwan.
(bombs exploding)
The rocket force recently
demonstrated its capability
to strike Taiwan during a conflict.
- Subordinate to Base 61 are a number
of brigades involved in
the targeting of Taiwan
during missile tests,
when Nancy Pelosi visited
Taiwan in August, 2022.
(bombs exploding)
- [Host] China conducted several
days of military exercises.
- A number of short and
intermediate range missiles
were launched into exclusion zones
to the north and south of Taiwan.
One of them was to the east and seaboard,
and there were also some
short range rocket firings
between Taiwan and Fujian province.
- [Host] China has been building up
its missile capacity
near Taiwan for years,
but drills during Pelosi's visit
demonstrate the rocket
force's new capability
to target the entire periphery of Taiwan.
- These brigades are one
of the sharpest tools in their arsenal
to mount a devastating
missile attack on the island
to blockade the island to
close off shipping lanes
and to mount a stranglehold
on the island during times
of political sensitivity.
- [Host] China views Taiwan's autonomy
and its links with the US as
a geostrategic vulnerability.
- So if we flip the map,
it depicts the challenge
that China is facing.
It's hemmed in to some degree
by the first island chain,
and to a lesser extent by
the second island chain.
It's a dilemma of oceanic geography,
but in a military sense,
this is why the rocket
force is so important.
The rocket force would play a key role
to prevent intervention
of the United States
and allies were at war
to break out over Taiwan.
(soft music)
- [Host] The Rocket forces
developed missiles capable
of striking US forces coming
to Taiwan's aid within the
first and second island chains.
One of these is the Don Fang 26,
known as the carrier killer.
The weapon has been deployed to a number
of brigades posing a challenge to the US.
- The DF-26 can be either
conventionally armed
or nuclear armed.
It can accurately target bases like Guam,
but it can also target an
aircraft carrier strike group.
So this presents a major challenge
for United States in terms
of its counter intervention campaign.
(bombs exploding)
- [Host] The Biden
administration has said US forces
will support Taiwan in the
event of a Chinese invasion.
China's rocket force now
presents a serious threat
to the US' ability to do that
dramatically raising the
stakes in any conflict
over the island.
China's ministry of defense
did not respond to a request
for comment.
(soft music)